so besides anti-semitic tweets besides
silence and besides defunding the police
what will the left do about this rise in
anti-semitic crime dennis prager joins
me now he's the founder and president of
prageru
and a nationally syndicated radio talk
show host and a very smart man who will
enlighten us all
on these issues dennis why the silence
from the left
on this issue you've really analyzed it
beautifully
it's the wrong perpetrators it's as
simple as that it's like
when i was uh when i was in college
which was not recently
i was taught this was at columbia in the
1970s
i was taught that a black cannot be a
racist
and i remember thinking that's that's
impossible i mean it's simply impossible
i couldn't believe i heard that but
every professor
uh who who addressed the issue said that
so the world of the left is a
make-believe world
but there is one point that i would like
to make that is extremely instructive
and has not been noted
and that is that these attacks are on
jews and they're coming from
a various muslim extremists in the
united states
obviously not from all muslims and i'm
not even implying that
but i people need to understand
something they don't understand
the middle east dispute is not over land
israel is the size of new jersey it is
smaller than el salvador
there are 22 arab states there is a
state with the majority of palestinians
called jordan
the issue is not land the issue is
religion
and again this is not what the left
wants you to believe they want you to
believe it's over
land right no it's not the uh the there
is a big chunk of the muslim world
that would like to exterminate the
jewish state beginning with of course
iran
that is why if you look at the rhetoric
it's always f the jews
f the jews in all of these attacks it's
never f the israelis
it's always f the jews right you know
dennis couple of points here first of
all you're absolutely right we opened
the show tonight talking about the idea
that lori lightfoot's policies in
chicago
are blatantly racist but there's this
belief out there that because she is
black she's
it's impossible for her to be racist
that only white people can be racist and
most sane people realize racism is an
individual sin that anyone
can commit but what you're saying that
is so fascinating right now and
understanding the issue between not just
israel and palestine but the jewish
people
is that when you see videos like the
ones we're playing where people are
driving down 42nd street the diamond
district here in new york city and
yelling something about zionism
to american jews they're not talking
about israel they're talking about
something else aren't they
well they're talking about yes
anti-semitism
as i well it is by the way there's a
very simple way to prove it
if the only country in the world you
think does not have the right to exist
is the only jewish country in the world
then one has the right to infer
that you have something against a jewish
state but not
any other state imagine somebody saying
you know i love italians
i'm not anti-italian but i don't think
italy has the right to exist
you would say sir i'm not an idiot you
hate italy and you hate italians
that's the way it works if the only
state that can't exist on earth is a
jewish state
you have something against the jews
that's exactly right if you have a
problem with jews in israel a problem
with jews and jordan a problem with jews
in
iran if you have a problem with jews in
new york city your issue is not about
land your issue is about anti-semitism
dennis prager
thank you so much for your time tonight
thank you
all right